when the young kids on the street found
out that I was working on Star Wars I
was like a god to them those kids are
now parents they've seen the movies
throughout the years there's always in
the back of the mind like all I remember
playing with it Falcon I remember
playing with the x-wing and the TIE
fighter
to understand that you have a small part
of that kind of bigger world is is
pretty cool
my name is Mark Boudreau and I've been
fortunate enough to work on Star Wars
toys since 1977
amazing thing about Star Wars I don't
think it's really ever gone away it's
always been there vehicles has been sort
of what I really am the most passionate
about TIE fighters x-wings Rey's speeder
that I have always built models built
planes cars so they said hey mark why
don't you go ahead and start working on
the Millennium Falcon
that's like sure why not
and lane falcon is more than just a
machine it really is a character that
helps save the day it's more than just a
hunkajunk he wanted to be able to
provide an experience that could extend
in the film so when you went to go see
the movie you come right back and you're
playing with Luke you're playing with
Han you're playing with Chewie and
you're able to relive everything that
you saw in the film one after I've gone
to the force wherever that might be
this product will still be there
grandkids from now will hopefully still
be enjoying Star Wars and we certainly
want to try to do our small part into
making sure that that continues